hallo ihr Lieben wir liegen wie ihr
hoffentlich auch mit ein oder zwei
Schoko Osterhasen auf der Couch ihr
müsst aber nicht ganz auf die tägliche
Dosis True Crime verzichten denn um euch
die Feiertage und die Wartezeit bisher
wieder da sind zu verkürzen haben wir
für euch das Osterspezial die großen
Tatort Deutschland Dokus mit Sky du Mont
für alle die neu dabei sind die sind
noch aus der Zeit als wir das ganze hier
nicht täglich gemacht haben also lasst
es euch gut gehen und viel Spaß
[Musik]
die Leute greifen bei Männern wie mir
immer zu drastischen Maßnahmen ich habe
grundsätzlich eine 9mm dabei gehabt
beim abendlichen Spaziergang durch
Hamburg hat der Mann zu dem diese Stimme
gehört maximal ein neues Smartphone bei
sich vor 20 Jahren ging Jan Sander auch
Miami Jenny genannt das letzte Mal durch
das Rotlichtviertel der Hansestadt hier
war er Türsteher alle kannten ihn nur
wenig später macht er sich in der Szene
als Zuhälter einen Namen er wäre noch
heute perfekt für den zwielichtigen Job
fast 2 Meter groß breit wie ein
Wohnzimmerschrank und mit Oberarmen wie
manche Oberschenkel haben grau-blaue
Augen funkeln aus dem braun gebrannten
Gesicht mit drei Tage Bart heraus aber
der Blick ist nicht aggressiv er
aufgeweckt und weich und passt nicht so
recht zur restlichen martialischen
Erscheinung des 42-Jährigen aber diese
Augen haben viel gesehen
Miami weiß Bescheid über die Kriminellen
Spielchen auf der Reeperbahn zur Genüge
damals wie heute das war damals bekannt
in Hamburg das durch und Scheckkarten
betrug sehr viel Gelder eingenommen
werden es war bekannt dass grundsätzlich
auch 18 19 20-Jährige zur Prostitution
nicht unbedingt gezwungen werden aber
überredet werden zur meiner Zeit und das
ist bis heute auch so geblieben war die
marekbande sehr aktiv mit eigenen
Etablissements Clubs sowie
Zimmervermietung die Hells Angels und
auch Albaner aber auch die
türsteher-szene war damals schon hart
umkämpft also immer mehr Albaner
mischten damit und gleichzeitig auch
Iraner und natürlich die Türken die
waren sehr aktiv vorbei was keine ahnte
der immer fitte respektierte und teils
gefürchtete Miami führt ein gefährliches
Doppelleben
[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
der Baumann an der Cover im
Rotlichtmilieu
Jenny arbeitet damals für das
Landeskriminalamt in Hamburg und sammelt
heimlich für die Polizei wichtige
Informationen im Kies jetzt und hier
packte über seine Vergangenheit aus
[Musik]
Anfang 2000 immer wieder brechen
revierkriege zwischen den zuhälterbanden
aus Schlägereien Messerangriffe sogar
Schüsse sind an der Tagesordnung die
Hackordnung auf dem Kiez wird sehr
blutig ausgekämpft es geht hauptsächlich
um Frauen und das Geschäft welche
verweht anschafft und um zig Millionen
D-Mark die Polizei versteckt zunehmend
ihre Präsenz auf der Reeperbahn
regelmäßig finden in Bordellen und
Laufhäusern Razzien statt ermittelt wird
gegen die Betreiber wegen
Steuerhinterziehung Menschenhandel und
sexueller Ausbeutung was mein
Schwerpunkt war im Zusammenarbeit mit
dem Behörden da lag mein Fokus
grundsätzlich immer auf Gewaltdelikte
gegen Frauen auf auf schwere Gewalttaten
zum Nachteil von Frauen ich habe Sachen
erlebt im Rotlicht und da muss man
leider Gottes sagen meistens sogar durch
durch Ausländer das ist normal so
nah gerade die die Zuhälter vom Balkan
oder auch aus der Türkei die nehmen da
überhaupt keine Rücksicht für die zählt
einfach nur der finanzielle Profit es
gab Situationen in denen ich wegschauen
musste
weil ich
dann aufgeflogen wäre und das sind
natürlich so Sachen die nimmst du auch
mit nach Hause und Janis zu Hause ist
der Kiez er bekommt täglich die Stimmung
unter den Kriminellen mit ist Teil des
Szene und wandelt immer auf dem schmalen
Grad zwischen Beobachter und Täter ich
kann mich da an eine Situation erinnern
da habe ich von einer Informantin den
Hinweis bekommen dass wohl in einem
billig-modell eine Minderjährige
anschaffen soll zu unserem Erstaunen war
diese angeblich Minderjährige im Besitz
eines deutschen
Personalausweises der sie als
24-Jähriger auswies doch danach
stellte sich raus dass die
überprüfte Person im Besitz eines
gefälschten Ausweises sei
und
nicht nur minderjährig sein sondern
gerade mal 13 Jahre alt
Janni tauscht sich dennoch regelmäßig
mit den LKA-Beamten aus die Orte dafür
sind beliebig und in der Öffentlichkeit
sie dürfen nicht auffallen deshalb
treffen sich die Männer häufig
konspirativ im Restaurant eines
Kaufhauses bei Café und Kuchen denn die
Polizei Hamburg setzt im Bereich
organisierte Kriminalität kurz ok
genannt sogenannte Vertrauensleute ein
sie sind ein wichtiges Mittel zur
Aufklärung schwerer Straftaten
Timo Zill Pressesprecher der Polizei
Hamburg nimmt in seinem schmucklosen
Büro an einer großen Tasse Kaffee er
weiß dass der Einsatz von V-Leuten sehr
umstritten ist gerade was die
organisierte Kriminalität aber auch
Rechtsextremismus betrifft trotzdem
sieht er die gewinnbringenden Aspekte
deutlich Frau Leute sind für uns in
diesem Milieu extrem wichtig es ist
natürlich ein sehr sehr abgeschlossener
Bereich es wird unwahrscheinlich viel
Geld damit gemacht ist ein großes Elend
häufig reden wir ja auch über Sex und
Ausnutzung von osteuropäischen Frauen
und deswegen haben wir natürlich ein
hohes Maß an Interesse dort tätig zu
werden und das gelingt uns häufig eben
nur über Menschen die in diesem Million
unterwegs sind dafür brauchen wir dieses
Instrument der Frau Leute ja es ist eine
graue sehr dunkle Schattenwelt die diese
Übergangsphase von Kriminalität und
Verbrechensbekämpfung ausmacht nicht
alle sind dafür geeignet Leben starken
Nerven und Planung im Vorgehen braucht
es auch physische stärken
Muckibude in Hamburg hier bewegt der
ex-türsteher noch heute täglich einige
Tonnen Stahl im stetigen Rhythmus gegen
die Gravitation die an den gewaltigen
Handeln zieht den Oberkörper frei
präsentiert Miami Gianni nicht nur die
schiere Fülle an Szene und Rocker
Tätowierungen auch die großen Narben
sind nichts übersehen ich bin in meiner
Internatszeit natürlich unter vielen
auch schwer erziehbaren jungen gewesen
die Gewalt eingesetzt haben und
schwächere zu unterdrücken und da war es
eigentlich Pflicht dass man sich schützt
indem man sich körperlich fit hält ich
wollte immer groß sein breit sein
maskulin sein ich habe dicke Arme dicke
Beine breite Schultern große
Brustmuskeln bewundert ich bin in der
Erde das Arnold Schwarzenegger groß
geworden in den 80ern 90ern und ähm habe
mich immer an diesen Leuten orientiert
[Musik]
Jenny wird 1977 als Jan Sander im
nordrhein-westfälischen Ratingen geboren
seine Mutter ist deutsche sein Vater
Syrer die Eltern trennen sich als Jan
noch ein Baby ist seine Mutter heiratet
an wenig später einen wohlhabenden
Geschäftsmann der zwei Kinder mit in die
Ehe bringt zwischen den
Stiefgeschwistern gibt es regelmäßig
Ärger Jan will nicht der schwächere sein
er beginnt mit Bodybuilding und
Kampfsport die Leute greifen leider
Gottes bei Männern wie mir immer zu
drastischen Maßnahmen und das geht zum
Teil dann aber auch böse für mich aus
ich habe unter anderem eine
Stichverletzung am Oberarm ich habe zwei
Stichverletzungen unterm Kinn am
Halsbereich das mit der Kontrahent auf
dem Rücken gesprungen ich habe 2007
einen Kopfschuss erlitten von hinten
beigefügt durch Marcel in Hamburg
ich habe zwei steckschüsse im hinteren
Oberschenkelbereich gehabt ich hatte
unter anderem mal eine
Auseinandersetzung da ist der Kontrahent
auf mich zu mit einem dekoschwert mich
hier an der Wade erwischt und hier oben
den Oberschenkel mit den sehen darunter
abgetrennt mit über 20 Stichen genäht
Jenny legt kurz die Hanteln beiseite
dann zieht der Grinsen die Sporthose
etwas herunter und präsentiert sein
muskulöses Hinterteil dort befindet sich
ein Muster tiefer gezackter Narben die
sich in einem Kreis anordnen solche
Verletzungen lassen sich leider Gottes
nicht vermeiden und auch sowas
unangenehmes wie eine abgebrochene
Flasche nicht
da kam der Kontrahent der lag schon auf
dem Boden ich mit dem Rücken zu heben
und da hat er mir noch eine abgebrochene
Bierflasche sehr unschön
in den Gluteus Maximus gerannt was auch
nicht genäht werden konnte da die
glasplitter raus wachsen müssen weil die
sich sonst entzündet er zieht die
Trainingshose wieder hoch und trocknet
sich den Schweiß ab er betrachtet sich
in der Spiegelfront des hantelraumes es
war für mich immer ein muss erst in der
Security Branche als Türsteher dann
danach Tätigkeit für die Behörden in den
verschiedenen Subkulturen in der nicht
eingesetzt worden bin bereichoka und
dann gerade auch dazu
dieser Körperkult auch immer ein Thema
johnny ist nun Anfang der 2000er in der
Hamburger Szene angesehen er wird
respektiert viele vertrauen ihm doch der
30-Jährige wird getrieben von seinem
eigenen Ehrgeiz er möchte noch
einflussreicher werden noch tiefer in
die Szene eintauchen um noch mehr Geld
zu verdienen und noch mehr Informationen
für die Behörden zu sammeln denn neben
der Prostitution haben sich im Hamburger
Rotlichtmilieu mittlerweile neue
Geschäftszweige gebildet der Drogen und
Waffenhandel floriert und wirft
Millionen ab Jenny trifft eine wichtige
Entscheidung eröffnet das Tropicana und
ist ab sofort Chef seines eigenen FKK
Clubs das Problem war damals das dafür
keine Mittel freigegeben worden sind
eine Behörde wird niemals ein
Modellbetrieb finanziert mit
Steuergeldern und ähm da ich aber
mittlerweile ganz gut in der Szene
zurecht kam und auch über die ein oder
anderen Kontakte zu Frauen verfügte habe
ich mich dann auch dazu hinreißen lassen
aus eigenem Geld aus Mitteln die mir aus
dem Milieu zur Verfügung standen diesen
Bordellbetrieb zu finanzieren
auf dem Kiez haben auch die Rocker der
Hells Angels Bordelle Laufhäuser Bars
und Diskotheken fast überall hat die
internationale Gang des sagen Gianni
beteiligt sie auch an seinem Club er
verspricht sich dadurch mehr Einfluss
und Schutz es ist eine
Verteidigungsstrategie nach vorn nach
dem Motto warst du nicht ändern kannst
musst du begrüßen ich habe mir damals
durch den Verkauf der Anteile im
Tropicana folgendes versprochen und zwar
erstmal eine Partnerschaft die mich in
höhere Kreise einführt der organisierten
Kriminalität wir wollten damit natürlich
dann auch den goldenen Wurf landen
daraufhin habe ich natürlich dann auch
dementsprechend Prozente abgegeben und
zwar
50%. damit da überhaupt auch Interesse
entsteht bei mir ging es ja mit dem
Betreiben des tropicanas nicht um Geld
und bei mir ging es einfach darum den
Fuß in die Szene zu kriegen auf einer
höheren Ebene
doch das Geschäft mit den Hells Angels
platzt die Rocker steigen vorzeitig aus
und wollen nun ihre Investitionen zurück
durch das Ausscheiden meiner
eigentlichen Partner mussten die ja aus
bezahlt werden ich hatte damals nicht
die finanziellen Mittel um das jetzt mal
eben zu machen wir sprechen ja über eine
Summe von
50.000 Euro und mehr eines Tages stand
ein junger Versicherungsmakler bei mir
im Laden der die Bücher einsehen wollte
und es stellte sich heraus dass er wohl
von einem sehr bekannten Gewalttäter aus
dem Hamburger Rotlichtmilieu Prozente
von meinem Laden angeboten bekommen
hatte die er teuer bezahlte das Geld
aber wohl nie angekommen war
normalerweise hätte der Hells Angel
damit bezahlt werden müssen das ist aber
wohl nicht geschehen da ist nur ein
Bruchteil von dem Geld angekommen und
somit stellte sich dann heraus dass
dieser Junge Versicherungsmakler nach
Kitzingen hier betrogen worden war bei
dem vermeintlichen Club Vermittler
handelt es sich um den stadtbekannten
Gewalttäter Marcel m auch bekannt als
Knochenbrecher Marcel seine
betrügerische Aktion mit dem
Versicherungsmakler macht Janni in der
Szene öffentlich er provoziert damit die
Gegenreaktion und die folgt
nach einem brutalen Überfall in Hamburg
Wandsbek in der Ahrensburger Straße
haben drei Männer in der Nacht den
Saunaclub Tropicana FKK 66 gestürmt
unter ihnen auch der stadtbekannte
Schläger Marcel m die Täter schlugen den
Geschäftsführer des Clubs Jan es nieder
auch Schüsse fehlen die Polizei geht von
einer auftragsschlägerei aus die
Angreifer konnten flüchten
sein Besuch in Hamburg führt Jenny
wieder an den Platz des Geschehens den
Club Tropicana gibt es nicht mehr der
schmucklose Bau ist neu beschildert die
Wände Lagerhallen weiß ein Zaun um den
Parkplatz Schotte das Gebäude heute ab
Jenny zeigt auf einen Anbau hier vorne
der Anbau
war mein Büro
da hat sich damals die Schießerei
ereignet die Angreifer sind hier über
den Eingangsbereich drüben zum Laden
haben geklingelt sind reingelassen
worden und haben dann mit vier Personen
das Büro gestürmt und haben da das Feuer
auf mich eröffnet
Timo 10 von der Polizei Hamburg kann
sich auch noch gut erinnern es gab eine
Auseinandersetzung in der Folge man hat
dann die Täter aus dem Büro rausgedrückt
offensichtlich dabei gab es einen
Schussabgabe in die Decke verletzt wurde
keiner man hat dann die Tür zudrücken
können und durch die geschlossene Tür
ist dann noch mal geschossen worden wo
ich dann hinterher noch den Schuss ins
Knie abwehren konnte und die Angreifer
sind geflüchtet der frisch gebackene
tropikanische Chef kommt verletzt ins
Krankenhaus die beiden Angreifer stellen
sich wenige Tage später bei der Polizei
der Überfall ist für Janni ein weghof er
wird noch vorsichtiger ohnehin schon ist
doch sein Leben ist weiterhin in akuter
Gefahr er rüstet sich nach Gangster
Mania aus und befolgt einige
grundlegende Regeln des Selbstschutzes
ich habe grundsätzlich einen 9 mm dabei
gehabt die hatte ich meistens am Körper
versteckt ich hatte zu Hause eine Waffe
im Schlafzimmer und ich habe natürlich
auch regelmäßig die Autos gewechselt ich
habe unter die Autos geschaut wenn
irgendwas war Bomben oder Zeitzünder
oder irgendwelche Bremsleitungen
manipuliert waren also ich war immer
gewarnt und auf Strom
sein Gefühl täuscht die nicht denn der
nächste Feind laut bereits in der
Hansestadt ein albanischer
Auftragskiller getan als italienischer
Zuhälter hat es auf Jenny abgesehen und
wartet auf den abschlussbefehl seiner
Auftraggeber in einem Internetcafé
treffen er und Gianni sich zum ersten
Mal Janni ist von Anfang an misstrauisch
willigt aber ein dem Fremden Besucher
seine Stadt zu zeigen beide Unternehmen
eines Sightseeing-Tour in Jannis Wagen
damals als als ich Besuch vom Keller
hatte der in meinem Auto saß und ich an
einer Tankstelle in Hamburg getankt
hatte ist mir aufgefallen dass er mit
einem Tuch über die Armaturen
Strich erwischte überall da wo er
angefasst hatte um ja seine Spuren zu
verwischen und das kam mir doch damals
sehr verdächtig vor da wurde ich dann
hellhörig und war dann auch gewarnt
Janni meldet in einer unbeobachteten
minute seinen Verdacht dem LKA in
Hamburg die erkennen die gefährliche
Situation für ihren vauern die LKA Leute
sahen das damals genauso wie ich da muss
wohl was im Bus sein der Vorteil damals
war dadurch dass er dachte dass wir
eventuell noch weiterfahren hatte er
sein Gepäck bei mir im Wagen vergessen
seine Tasche nicht nur die ganzen
wegwerf Handys waren in dieser Tasche zu
finden auch ein komplett neues Outfit
und eine Plastiktüte mit einem nassen
Handtuch was mit Wasserstoffperoxid
behandelt worden war was als
Bleichmittel und Desinfektionsmittel
eingesetzt wird ich gehe davon aus dass
er vor hatte mich zu Hause zu töten
Jenny schmiedet nun gemeinsam mit dem
LKA einen Plan sie wollen unbedingt an
die Personalien des Albaners kommen
dafür täuschen sie vor seinem Hotel eine
Polizeikontrolle vor die Aktion glückt
aber die Beamten können den verdächtigen
Mann nicht verhaften und müssen ihn
laufen lassen ein paar Tage später
bekommt Jenny eine überraschende
Nachricht
gegen Abend habe ich dann einen Anruf
bekommen dass meine Vermutung wohl
richtig gewesen ist dass der bereits in
der Verhandlung war wegen anderen
Tötungsdelikten und international
gesucht wurde mir ist bekannt dass er
wohl zwei oder drei Tage später an einer
europäischen Grenze festgenommen werden
konnte und wurde dann zum Verhör nach
Hamburg verbracht letzten Endes haben
die Ereignisse in Hamburg
unter anderem auch die Begegnung mit
meinem Killer dazu geführt dass ich in
Nordrhein-Westfalen mich für den
nächsten Einsatz gemeldet habe und
Rocker geworden bin
2010 verlässt Johnny endgültig Hamburg
das Pflaster im Kiez ist ihm zu heiß
geworden er will zur Ruhe kommen und
zieht wieder in seine alte Heimat nach
Ratingen in Nordrhein-Westfalen mit
seinem Kontaktmann vom LKA Hamburg
bleibt in Verbindung Anfang 2012 treffen
sie sich am Düsseldorfer Flughafen
wieder zu dem Gespräch kommen
überraschend auch die Kollegen vom LKA
Nordrhein-Westfalen der Plan Gianni soll
zukünftig undercover als Vormann
zwischen rein und Ruhe arbeiten ich
hatte angeboten einen arabischen Plan in
Nordrhein-Westfalen zu infiltrieren der
sich in der Rockerszene in einem
sogenannten Migranten chapter vor mir
wollte Jennys silobjekt ist der
Rockerclub Türkiye Bosporus ein
migrantenableger von Europas größte
Rockerclub dem Gremium MC viele
Mitglieder sind türkische Herkunft in
der Gründungsphase hat vor allem die
libanesische Großfamilie als sein das
Sagen durch den starken Zulauf von
Arabern steigt das migrantenchapter in
kürzester Zeit in das Szene auf und
dringt auch in die Hoheitsgebiete von
den Bandidos und Hells Angels ein für
das Landeskriminalamt in
Nordrhein-Westfalen eine beunruhigende
Situation
Ärger ist programmiert Frank Schollen
vom LKA in NRW ist froh dass es Typen
wie journey gibt die ihre Tarnung Leben
gerade im Bereich der Rockerkriminalität
da wird es mir kaum gelingen wenn ich
jemanden platzieren möchte der
Anzugträger ist der mit weißem Hemd
rumläuft und mit einer Krawatte das
heißt da muss ich schon passgenau
schauen wen kann ich da nehmen und als
eines der Ultima Ratio was wir haben ist
dann eben der Einsatz von V Personen das
ist ein anerkanntes Mittel der
Strafverfolgung das ist durch
Obergerichte durch das
Verfassungsgericht abgeklärt insofern
nutzen wir das auch Gianni baut sich
eine überprüfbare Legende auf die sich
weit gehend mit seiner Zeit in Hamburg
deckt der Hauptkontakt
von mir war zu einem Mitglied einer
arabischen Großfamilie aus Essen dem
elsen-clan ich fungierte damals als
Zuhälter aus Hamburg Rotlicht Boss aus
Hamburg der nun in NRW seine Geschäfte
machen wollte weil er durch diverse
Konflikte mit dem
Rotlichtmilieu in Hamburg eine Person
Ahnung rata war in gewisser Weise
stimmte das ja auch und Überprüfung
durch den Clan hielt stand Jennys erste
Auftrag des Clans
er soll in der Essener Diskothek Essens
Frauen für die Prostitution akquirieren
dafür bekommt der freien Eintritt im
Club doch die Kleinbusse haben
knallharte Bedingungen man forderte von
mir gut 10000 € wöchentlich das sind ca
eine halbe Million Euro im Jahr damit
ich hier in Nordrhein-Westfalen
unbehelligt meine
prostitutionsgeschäfte
ausüben könnte Jonny sieht das als nicht
machbar an geht in die nicht ein und
bricht den Kontakt ab
er schläustt sich bei einem anderen
Gremium MC Ableger ein
er wird jetzt Rocker bei Boss Bruce West
hier versucht er für die Behörden an
wichtige Informationen über
clubstrukturen und die Geschäftsbereiche
zu kommen aber es gibt nicht allzu viel
zu berichten das Positive muss man
tatsächlich sagen war das man sich
damals tatsächlich nicht einig wurde das
heißt von anfänglich 80 Mann die bei der
Gründung dabei waren blieben 30 Mann
über hauptsächlich Leute aus Dinslaken
Lohberg weil der eigentlich Präsident
auch aus Dinslaken nur bei stammte er
hatte aber in keinster was
organisatorisches Talent oder auch in
keinster Weise die Möglichkeit
diese Leute zu führen und so war es
vorprogrammiert dass sich dieses chapter
in seiner Einzelteile zerlegte die
gewünschten Ermittlungserfolge also
bleiben aus Jenny beendet nach zehn
Monaten seinen Einsatz bei Boss bewusst
doch eine neue noch gefährlichere
rockergruppierung macht bereits von sich
reden
ein Ableger des berüchtigten
holländischen Motorradclubs satudara
will Deutschland erobern die Polizei in
Duisburg ist sofort alarmiert mit dieser
Gruppe ist nicht zu spaßen
Polizeihauptkommissar Steffen Hausch in
Duisburg schiebt die Papiere auf seine
Schreibtisch zu Recht wir wussten
natürlich durch Informationsaustausch
mit unseren niederländischen Kollegen
das satuldaran in Holland stark
verfeindet mit den Hells Angels waren
die haben da gut grundlegendes Angels
gemacht es kam zu Tötungsdelikten und es
war so dass 2012 zum Beispiel fünf der
zehn meistgesuchten Verbrecher in den
Niederlanden Mitglieder bei Saturn waren
dafür bekannt dass sie im Bereich der
Gewaltkriminalität und der organisierten
Kriminalität tätig waren vor wegen dem
Drogenbereich und im Bereich der
Prostitution
satudara bedeutet wörtlich übersetzt ein
Blut der erste Club wird 1990 in Holland
eröffnet die Gründungsmitglieder stammen
von den molukkeninseln bis 1945 ist
diese Inselgruppe eine niederländische
Kolonie heute gehört sie zu Indonesien
weltweit haben die Holländer Rocker
dutzende chapter eröffnet neben ihrem
Hauptsitz in den Niederlanden gibt es
Ableger in Belgien Spanien Indonesien
Malaysia und in den USA im Frühjahr 2012
expandiert der Club nach deutschland
übernimmt den MC Brotherhood Clown town
mit knapp 30 Mitgliedern
[Musik]
auch Gianni wechselt zu den sogenannten
schwarz-gelben in Duisburg eröffnen sie
ihr erstes Clubhaus eine eindeutige
Kampfansage an die Hills Angels
Ortsbegehung in Duisburg Gianni steht
kopfschüttelnd auf dem großen Parkplatz
vor dem leichter runtergekommenen zum
Teil als Wohnhaus genutzten Gebäude hier
war früher der Eingangsbereich ist heute
verbarrikadiert hier hing große
gelb-schwarze Schilder die den Club ganz
klar
erkennen ließ zu erkennen ließen hier
wurden unter anderem Anschläge geplant
Partys geplant etc hier wurden alle
Vorbereitungen betroffen für Club
interne Angelegenheiten ich stand in
meiner Anfangszeit im Saturn Duisburg
natürlich auch mit Funkgerät hier vorne
und musste aufpassen dass hier keiner
Übergriffe stattfanden oder
verfeinerte Rocker versuchten das
Treiben von uns hier auszuspionieren der
damalige
Präsident Ali Osman alias yildirai car
hat zu diesem Zeitpunkt nur ein Ziel er
will mit allen Mitteln die Hells Angels
im Ruhrgebiet entmachten der neue
Rockerkrieg droht endgültig zu
eskalieren
Polizeihauptkommissar Steffen Hausch
seufzt und schon damals bestätigten sich
alle seine Vermutungen das hat keine
zwei Monate gedauert nach der
Eröffnungsfeier da kam es zu mehreren
Angriffen auf Hells Angels Mitglieder
oder auf Gebäude die von Personen
betrieben wurden die in den Hells Angels
nahe standen im August 2012 hatte
zunächst ein satuldarer Funktionär muss
man sagen der sogenannte secretarif von
saturara 3 Schlüssel auf ein Auto eines
mutmaßlichen Hells Angels Mitglieds
abgegeben Gott sei Dank kam es dazu
keinen
verletzten noch im gleichen Monat gab es
zwei Handgranaten Anschläge einmal auf
einen Clubheim in
duisburghausen ein Clubheim der Hells
Angels zum anderen auf einen Wettbüro
das am nächsten Tag eröffnet werden
sollte natürlich war so wenn die eine
Seite provoziert hat also da Gegenübers
dir die erklärten Feinde waren dann hat
auch die Gegenseite das nicht auf sie
sitzen lassen und zurückgeschlagen da
kam es zu schützen von Hells Angels auf
das da Clubhaus und das macht eigentlich
deutlich dass das eigentlich ein Bruder
was war
ein handgranatenanschlag auf ein
Wettbüro von Hells Angels Unterstützern
in Duisburg Großeinsatz der Polizei im
Duisburger Rotlichtviertel angeblich
gibt es Hinweise auf eine
Auseinandersetzung zwischen verfeindeten
Rockerclubs tödliche Schießerei vor
einem Schnellrestaurant in Oberhausen
dabei wird ein Mitglied der Hells Angels
schwer verletzt er muss operiert werden
[Musik]
man wollte diesen Krieg aufführen mit
allen Mitteln es ging tatsächlich darum
wirklich diesen Club hier in Deutschland
zu etablieren also ich kann bestätigen
das von Handgranaten bis panzerforsten
über Kalaschnikow alles da war was man
für einen Krieg braucht die Holländer
meines tot Ernst im März 2013 wills Hato
darara dann seine Vormachtstellung
gegenüber den Hells Angels endgültig
festigen die Mitglieder schmieden einen
tödlichen Plan mit Kriegswaffen ziel ist
es Rotlichtviertel in Duisburg es ist
nicht weit und Jenny fährt an die
Kreuzung in einem eher vorstehtisch
industriell geprägten Teil von Duisburg
breite Straße und wenig Fußgänger hier
waren auch damals die Anschläge geplant
durch den Tattoo daran MC hier wollte
man zuschlagen es gab hier zwei
Zielobjekte die mir noch am gleichen Tag
bekannt waren ich habe natürlich dann
sofort meine Führung beim LKA informiert
damit die die nötigen sicherungs- und
Schutzmaßnahmen hochfahren können und
einleiten können um diese zu verhindern
und die Sicherheitskräfte der Polizei
reagieren sofort Fotos auf dem Rechner
von Polizeihauptkommissar Steffen Hausch
zeigen Waffen und selbstgebaute
haftladungen mit militärischem
Sprengstoff mit diesem Sprengstoff
sollte ein Anschlag auf das
Rotlichtviertel in Duisburg verübt
werden darüber hinaus gab es Hinweise
dass mittels einer Panzerfaust die aus
den Niederlanden eingeführt werden
sollte ebenfalls das Rotlichtviertel in
Duisburg angegriffen werden sollte wir
haben durch starke Polizeipräsenz und
intensive Kontrollmaßnahmen im Rotlicht
über eine ganze Zeit lang verhindert
dass es hier zu einem solchen Szenario
kommt bei so viel Präsenz der
Staatsmacht halten sich die Rocker
zurück aber wer hat gesungen wer hat es
der Polizei gesteckt
Jennys Frau Mann Tätigkeit für das LKA
droht an dem Abend aufzufrieden einzelne
satudara Mitglieder fangen an ihm zu
misstrauen er muss seine Position wieder
stärken und unbedingt den waren Janis
Taktik ist wieder die Flucht nach vorn
er will den Kurs bestimmen als
offizieller klubsprecher geht an die
Öffentlichkeit lädt zusammen mit dem
Präsidenten der yildirai Car die Presse
ins Duisburger Clubhaus für die Behörden
ist die Lage im Ruhrgebiet weiterhin
bedrohlich damit der Rockerkrieg nicht
noch einmal eskaliert greift die Polizei
hart durch und für Gianni wird es noch
enger im April 2013 in einem großen
Showdown sozusagen
unter Federführung der Duisburger
Polizei 33
Durchsuchungsbeschlüsse er wird und
vollstreckt haben zahlreiche Haftbefehle
sowohl in Deutschland als auch in den
Niederlanden im Zuge dieser Maßnahmen
wurde auch der Präsident von Duisburg
festgenommen der Monate später
umfangreich außerhalb der zu
tagplanungen zu Bewaffnungen zu
hierarchischen Strukturen innerhalb von
satuldarer sowohl hier als auch in den
Niederlanden trotz der ermittlungser
setzt Gianni seine Aufklärungsarbeit für
die Behörden fort eigentlich wäre es
Zeit für ihn die Wogen sich glätten zu
lassen aber der adrenalinjunkie kann
nicht anders als die Gefahr und ja auch
Anerkennung zu suchen ich habe dann nach
der Verhaftung von Juli 3k und baroté
die Möglichkeit gehabt in der Rocker
Hierarchie im chapter aufzusteigen ich
habe den
die Position des vizepräses inner gehabt
was mir ermöglichte
nicht direkt an den Entscheidungen
beteiligt zu sein aber dennoch genug
mitzubekommen dass man einschreiten kann
und auch dirigieren kann eines Tages
weil sich der Rockerkrieg zuspitzte und
ich im Raum Düsseldorf wohnte im Hells
Angels Gebiet wurde die
von mir benutzte Harley Landesmittel
polizeimaschine von vermutlich einem
Supporter Club der Hells Angels dem Clan
81 angezündet der Brandanschlag erfolgte
auf dem Grundstück meiner Familie da ist
nachts war schlief natürlich meine
gesamte Familie tief und fest und ähm es
wäre nicht auszudenken gewesen was da
dann noch alles hätte passieren können
ein Nachbar rufte danach die Feuerwehr
der Brand kann rechtzeitig gelöscht
werden die aus Landesmitteln finanzierte
Harley ist aber nicht versichert Gianni
muss eine schnelle Lösung finden und
gibt das Motorrad in die falschen Hände
verliert die Nerven und tritt damit die
nächste Kaskade los ich habe dann ein
Angebot bekommen von einem Hänger round
von einem ehemaligen Landstreicher aus
dem eigenen chapter der bot mir an diese
Maschine kostengünstig zu reparieren er
entpuppte sich aber als faules Ei er
nahm unter anderem zweieinhalb Tausend
Euro von mir
landesmittelbar Mittel die mir zur
Verfügung gestellt waren um mich im
rockermüll bewegen zu können Name an
sich
verprasste dieses Geld anstatt seine
Schulden zu regulieren oder Harley Teile
zu bestellen und mit Reparatur zu
beginnen Gianni platzt der Kragen und
erklärt die Situation auf satudara
Manier mit einer 9 mm Pistole will er
den korrupten Schrauber zur Rede stellen
er informiert das Elke an nicht über
diese Aktion jetzt ist er einfach nur
Miami Giani der Lude der Rocker der
Kampfsportler er bricht den Kontakt zur
Behörde ab Jenny bleibt in der
Rockerszene kündigt im Internet sogar
groß die Gründung seines eigenen
Motorradclubs an den mother Rocker MC er
überhebt sich verliert sich selbst in
den Lügen den dunklen Geschäften und dem
täglichen Stress dann schlägt erneut das
Schicksal zu ich bin dann leider Gottes
während der Planung des Ganzen im
November 2013 durch einen
Sondereinsatzkommando der Polizei
verhaftet worden Tat Vorwurf ich soll
einen schweren Raub begangen haben zwei
billig-telefone und ein billig Tablet PC
im Wert von 16 Euro geraubt haben zwei
Unbeteiligte mit einer Schusswaffe
bedroht haben
Jenny sieht es in eine Falle getappt ist
wer sie gestellt hat das weiß er nicht
die Konsequenzen muss er so oder so
tragen sein Leben als Frau Mann und
Gangster ist nun endgültig vorbei Game
Over ich bin damals zu einer
Freiheitsstrafe von sechs Jahren
verurteilt worden durch das Landgericht
Mönchengladbach der Vorsitzende hatte
unter anderem seine
Urteilsbegründung damit formuliert dass
jemand der sich so wie ich in den
sozialen Netzwerken und in dem Medien
präsentiert hat es nicht anders verdient
ich habe von den sechs Jahren
sechs Jahre abgesessen im geschlossene
Vollzug im Hochsicherheitstrakt der JVA
der Bundesinnenminister Thomas de
Maizière hat den Rockerclub satudara
bundesweit verboten in
Nordrhein-Westfalen Bayern
Baden-Württemberg Niedersachsen und
Bremen stirnpolizisten Clubheime und
Wohnungen der Mitglieder sie
beschlagnahmen unter anderem Messer
Schlagstöcke Macheten und Gaspistolen
sowie Drogen Schutzwesten und Munition
das Doppelleben von Jan Sander alias
Miami Gianni ist endgültig Geschichte
eine Maskerade die er jahrelang 24
Stunden 7 Tage die Woche aufrecht hielt
dafür zahlt er bis heute einen hohen
Preis seine Familie und er haben bis auf
weiteres keinen Kontakt mehr eine
stabile Beziehung eine Aussicht auf ein
normales Leben sind erstmal nicht in
Sicht er hat noch Feinde und sollte
ihnen nicht in die Quere kommen jenny
hat seine Lektion aus der Vergangenheit
gelernt ich werde auch natürlich durch
die Verurteilung für keine Behörde mehr
tätig sein können ich habe weder
geheiratet in meinem Leben noch habe ich
einen intaktes Familienleben
und man stellt sich natürlich die Frage
zu welchem Preis hat man diesen Job die
letzten 20 Jahre ausgeübt eine gewisse
Enttäuschung kann Jan Sander nach all
den Einsätzen an der Cover nicht
verbergen und dennoch funkeln seine
Augen wieder frech seine letzte
Feststellung mag resigniert sein Gianni
selbst ist es ganz sicher nicht
Jenny sitzt im Sommer 2021 entspannt in
einem Korbsessel vor einer Baustelle es
ist Pause hier wird eine Diskothek neu
hergerichtet und Johnny voll mit
Gipsstaub von den Trockenbauwänden
leitet den Umbau tatsächlich ist das
jetzt das Leben danach nach Rocker nach
Milieu nach meiner Tätigkeit für die
Polizei und nach meiner langjährigen
Haft
versuche ich jetzt mit 42 in ein neues
Leben zu kommen in einen nicht unbedingt
bodenständiges und solides Leben nach
wie vor schillernd was zu mir passt
natürlich polarisiere ich auch dadurch
aber ich versuche meine Karriere jetzt
das Entertainer und als Schauspieler und
natürlich als Sänger das mit dem singen
und schauspielern ist eine Idee von
vielen die sich wegen der weltweiten
corona-pandemie etwas verschoben haben
daneben erstmal Handwerk und mit
anpacken das wird schon alles johnny hat
seit einiger Zeit doch eine feste
Freundin das gibt Stabilität der Hühner
erhebt sich er muss mal wieder
weitermachen sonst wird das nicht
rechtzeitig fertig meint er noch
zwinkert schelmisch und verschwindet dem
gipsnebel
[Musik]
in der nächsten Folge suchen wir
Erklärungen für den kaltblütigen
Kindermord von Herne im Fokus der heute
23-jährige Marcel Haar abonniere diesen
Podcast da wo du ihn hörst dann verpasst
du keine Ausgabe
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild produziert von den Wake world
Studios Projektleitung Lutz Neumann und
Simone terbrack Produktion Fabian
Scheffler und Felix Stäblein
Bildredaktion Kristin Wahl Frank
Schneider und Stefan Netzeband Sprecher
Sky du